hello welcome to this video the national
master d RK that's dr. copic Denny kopek
i'm not mistaken coppage and let's let's
check yep okay so he went with a clean
corn green creamed corn opening not very
aggressive black shouldn't have many
problems here but it's still very solid
for white oh that's very unambitious so
what now you should have five man maybe
maybe at night edge for him yeah I'm
kind of surprised that he's so on yeah
that he just does not do anything to Yap
to avoid this this kind of position that
he is in its not very very attractive
and okay he's got a form lined up
that's true that's absolutely true
huh hmm I wonder I wonder how to play
this he's going to play a form i have
some interesting ideas i can go bishop
here let's do this and after you for
cover that porn when the bishop only
three is a pretty pretty big obstacle to
come come by i wonder i can go up the
aid or castles long I don't worry both
moves I don't want to play really
rock da this condition since seven which
is quite annoying okay so let's do this
it's not ideal I wanted to use a look on
the phone hmm down down like a million
million minutes story of my blitz games
anyway this is a good position but i'm
down quite a bit of time it's good
because of the the bishops i have the
the good Bishop is bishop is not so
great I wonder at f5 as a move but he
will take of course huh how do I make
some progress in this position not so
easy night to be six might be an option
okay I go at five maybe place if I for
something stupid but so then he didn't
f3 Wow f3 is kind of surprising why
wouldn't you play Knight f3 sir it's
strange okay I mean the position is so
reasonably solid he can play and
probably wow
can play the odds second-rate move i'm
not losing without losing it whoa can
even take on take on d4 year threatens
92 it's pretty that's pretty dangerous
okay I'm doing that he's got some some
coordination issues here maybe he can
just about play king g4 but Kings you
for my might still be on 92 Bishop g3
it's pretty awful looking but maybe it's
just just about her walls fan but I
think he has to do that no his pieces
are completely completely uncoordinated
I recently learned of the q''-word
discom boo I cannot pronounce it haha
this compu belated or something like
that this come I cannot I cannot do it
okay so um yeah this is a good move
actually hmm ok
didn't have a look everyone on my on my
radar somehow let's let's run the sea
pawn this combo discombobulated
something like that and it's the right
word that I was looking for but I cannot
pronounce it that's not good so what is
this now the night is just about
stopping everything I'm worried need the
king over to d5 to see for something
like that
yeah that whole sacrifice was
interesting but ultimately not
sufficient can get 3 i've got 94 so
that's not a problem night see one you
can go but i have rupee for check okay
so i could rookie for chitchat an idea
for King f2 cheeks Teague's Kings you
for that okay the main issue is i have
to speed up and i can also take here and
it's not bad just snatching another pawn
check Nancy too I came but time this is
also good it's not as good as it could
have been but it wasn't terrible
18 seconds
okay need to move the King first or
something it's not Nyjah three is also
pretty good if I can get it in but I
don't get it in if I Teague and promote
here Scott no I'm promoting with check
of course check check check check check
a wild game it wasn't a correct
sacrificin like four things on time yeah
when he did it poster practical problems
but it probably wasn't entirely correct
so yeah the engine just wants to play
Bishop back in 2d eight but I know it's
it fit was certainly interesting like
here here before yeah well the computer
gives 0.4 or something not nothing
decisive for white yeah it's not not a
correct sacrifice push-up age to or skin
was right and around here he probably
should win rook f5s good now that's not
an easy move to make absolutely not
going away from the back rank it's a
very counterintuitive roxy five is a
strong threat down
it's probably the point yeah anyway yeah
this is justice losing check oh I can't
just take him play Knight f3 my thought
process was ok this is probably good but
why not just snatch your porn on edge
for of course I can just take the age to
Bishop and win easily ok me this is also
winning for blackjack c2 was even
quicker of course but that does win i
shattered does win chan it just took
took longer but to check and really and
put into question wow that was was a
tricky tricky game but ok sometimes you
can try and blitz games my opponents do
those kind of incorrect semi correct
sacrifices quite often so let's yeah for
once do it do it myself ok thanks for
watching